look great as always thank you so do you
please sir i know i'll talk to you later
fellas love me uh thanks so much for
being here you look fantastic
i want to ask you something because i
know that you take really good care of
yourself obviously you take great care
of
yourself
and your diet you're a vegan is that
right yeah vegan
means you there's no uh no animal
products no animal product
so i'm just curious thanksgiving coming
up you probably want to have a big
thanksgiving meal like everyone else
what are you going to eat well we
actually did an episode that airs this
week
not is it tonight yeah well yeah it's
tonight yeah so it's after you've
already missed it
yeah you missed it sapps
i think but it's uh jive turkey i think
it's called the episode
and we did a whole thing on thanksgiving
and so we have like a huge tofurky
and an turkey okay let's talk tofurky
is uh it's a it's a it's tofu yeah
and it's is it shaped like a turkey
there's two there's three different cool
kinds of tofurkeys you can get
one ish uh like a big smoked tofu tofu
but
in the shape of a turkey like like a
stamp of a turkey like
you know a sticker of a turkey right
yeah i mean it says
yeah but my question is why do they have
to have it in the shape of a turkey if
it's not a turkey
that the other one is a little bit scary
because it looks like a turkey it's like
a little guy going
you know it's a little sad it looks like
a turkey trying to get away
so i don't like that one as much right
right but it could be in the shape of
once you've got the tofu stuff it could
be in the shape of like ted koppel's
head it doesn't matter
exactly right it could be anything
that's why i like the one that just is
it looks like
a sticker of a turkey because it's just
friendly and funny and it's like
it's nice or it could be a smiley face
whatever it could be anything
uh now obviously uh i know that you've
you've be over the years and being
actually become very comfortable with
your body
i'm not comfortable with and in fact my
body
is comfortable with my body uh but
you're so you're
thank you uh but you're very comfortable
with your body so comfortable in fact
that i read that you
you garden in the nude is that true
sometimes i like to call it a little i
like to do a little naked gardening
naked garden naked gardening it's a
little thing we say in my home
right right i tell the dogs okay it's
time for naked gardening
so you're out in your garden and there's
you're not wearing anything are you
yeah because it makes it easier to get
around and then it's no it doesn't
mean it makes it easier to get around
that's just not true
i'm cumbered by pants i uh
no uh to jump on the trampoline it's fun
to jump on the trampoline naked
it's fun to jump in the pool naked those
i i see those things but
i know as a guy i don't want to be
around with sheers naked you know well
get rid of this you know no one wants
that
that's dangerous right you don't want
the shears i'm more like with my hands
delicately pruning the pretty well
that's nice that's like a nice
that's a nice image you're but what
about neighbors your neighbors must have
like a gong that they ring when you're
out
at least he's out new gardening bong
bong bong people come running from miles
around
does that happen not that i'm aware of
not that you're aware of
yeah insurance they've got duck blinds
and everything they're excited
so uh what about sunburn you have to
worry about sunburn i'm a big
i don't have a big concern about sun
burns you probably get a nice tan
yeah i i think a good healthy 20 minutes
in the sun a day
is like good vitamin d you know like
without sunblock you know it's nice
right so i burst into flames after five
minutes so yeah i literally do
i'm just like one of those stunt guys
covered in flame i can't go to the beach
you know i wear like a bear suit when i
go
that's sorry um now i understand you you
work very hard you make movies you
didn't watch a lot of
prime time television and the reason
that you got interested in television
because you got tivo
and i don't know how many people here
have tivo but tivo makes a huge
difference you can
so the rest of you don't know what we're
going to talk about now what are they
talking about
tivo's a martian uh a well-meaning
martian no tivo
is this device that helps look for
television shows that you like and it
saves them it's got a little computer
brain so that then you can watch tv at
your convenience
i don't appreciate it when they make
that judgment call for me like i like to
pick my
maybe i'm a bit controlling but i like
to pick you know you get to pick your
own shows
and they take it but then all of a
sudden they tape shows for you and
you're like why did you tape that you're
wasting my tape time
right on your choice tivo has this brain
and it's looking at what you watch
and then trying to figure out oh if you
like this you'll probably like that and
it goes and records it for you
when i got my tivo for the first time i
literally i swear to god i turned on the
tv with tivo attached and it was on hbo
it was at night and g-string divas was
on
okay so i watch for 40 minutes
just to see what's happened no i you
know i wat but then i literally i turned
the channel not long after that because
it was an episode i had seen and uh
but my girlfriend at the time later the
next time she turned on the tv
tv and she hadn't used it before tevo
said well
i know you like porn so here's all this
porn
and she suddenly said why does it think
that you like porn
[Applause]
yeah it's pretty good and i've never
seen porn since i don't really know what
it is
now on the show mismatch which which
you're doing now uh you play someone who
matches people up tries to get couples
into a romantic relationship
is that something you're any good at in
real life no
i try i mean you know every time
somebody tells me they're
single and looking for somebody i
immediately go okay i'm gonna help and
then i just sort of
my mind goes blank but now i feel
they're talking
they're probably hoping that it'll be
you you know what i mean when people are
telling you i'm single and i kind of
they're
you know they probably want you to go
okay you know let's go on a carriage
ride around the park but
uh but it's but it's hard for you to
hook someone up boo on the carriage
rides what's up with that
what are you talking about i don't think
that's nice
what like the horses oh right i forgot
oh no i meant with a tofurky dragging it
a tofurkey would be in front
i didn't mean carrots right i know those
are pounds
what's wrong with them who suggested
that
that guy in the back um but yes
it's so much fun and now i feel like
they should really i'm very credible
now that i'm playing a matchmaker people
think you know how to do it well i
think that they should right well they
think you should yeah next time i'm
gonna
use that like you know sort of i think i
should have a better sense of
matching now right working on it because
i want to identify with my character
just like okay you're an aries maybe you
could be good with a leo or
that kind of thing i guess i'm i'm
saying my brain goes blank like how do
you actually do it because then if you
set people up they're going to be like
why did you put me with that person i've
never
done it i've never even when i think
people are right for each other i don't
want to do it because i don't want to be
responsible for the pain and torment
later on
yeah do you know what i mean what if i
set somebody up and they end up getting
married and then
you know it doesn't work out i just i
don't want any part of that
that cause enough damage through the tv
show i don't need
to spread the hate other ways uh
mismatch airs friday nights
at nine on nbc great to see you again
thank you best of luck to you alyssia
silverstone everybody we'll be right
back